for anyone out there who enjoys
working from home in their softest
sweatpants anyone like to do that some
of us had some time at home
i mean you know there's some
in the industries they're like you got
to come back to the office people are
not giving up their sweatpants and now
science is behind you they say your
sweats make you better at your job
actually
yeah
the wall street journal reports a study
tested hundreds of people working at
home on zoom they had some dress up in
like formal business attire and others
like
were just in their casual comfies and
the results are in the comfy group was
the most engaged and immersed in their
tasks they felt the the most authentic
allowing them to feel very present in
their work
drew are you going to be elastic head to
toe from now on
i'm i'm a little surprised by that yeah
me too honestly and as a sweatpant
enthusiast um
i'm i am surprised by this because like
there's that i do kind of believe in
that whole like dress the part thing
yeah and every time i want to wear my
sweats like on a date my friends gasp as
if you know
it's the most horrible idea on the
planet it is the most you might as well
know where this is all ending up right
now
um but i i am surprised by this where do
we go from here i every big designer is
now making athleisure you know you go
i walked by a gucci it was all
sweatpants head to toe so uh maybe you
started a trend drew
no i think i've just thrown the towel in
and everybody else is doing they've
joined in yeah all right and finally
we've got a beautiful moment from oak
hill elementary school in georgia the
head custodian there lana gashenko is a
ukrainian with a family living back home
in ukraine and usa today reports that
the students at the school wanted to
show her that they were thinking about
miss lana so they put up this surprise
art project and it's dozens of
hand-drawn sunflowers the national
flower of ukraine and messages hoping
for peace and safety from miss lana's
family and all of ukraine
i know
i don't think that needs any words
[Music]
you